before we let you go we do have a
question from you for you
from our chat and um it's um
about gary's contribution to your game
you have worked with guy castro in the
past and i think it was in 2009 2010
uh what do you think has been the
biggest
contribution from that session that you
had with him in your career
um i think those sessions
helped me understood and understand the
dynamics of chess a lot
a lot better um and
it's been i mean sometimes i've been
able to
to use that knowledge and sometimes not
um
but um i i would say that's that's the
main
takeaway that's that's what he could do
a lot better than me uh even back back
then and
it's still like one of the most
difficult things
in chess did you guys work more on
openings or just uh the entire asp the
whole
or was it a more universal training uh
all aspects of the game
i would say quite universal but
obviously
um the main focus is gonna be
on on the openings at some point
all right thank you for your time and
your insights magnus and good luck for
your match tomorrow
thank you